[Música]
qual é a primeira coisa que vem à cabeça
quando pensam em uma prisão em uma
cadeia ou não estamos cimento prisional
e qual é a primeira coisa que vem à
vossa cabeça quando pensou no mosteiro
ou não com vendo a imagem que tal ver lá
em cima não é cra é um sonho utópico em
2000 e trança enquanto engenheiro
engenheiro do ambiente faz parte da
concessão do benefício
tratava da reabilitação de uma
plataforma petroleira franquia ao largo
de são francisco na califórnia
aí a forma como nossas estruturamos a
este projecto assenta havana poética de
ver a prisão como um lugar de
transformação estrutural esta canalha
era no meio do mar por isso não
precisava de 40
o próprio luciano criava o isolamento
suficiente uma pessoa precisava estar
para pensar na sua vida e para alguma
forma a aumentar a confiança consoante
usados que conta mas aquilo era uma
utopia aquilo foi um projeto que foi
premiado não foi pra frente
a realidade é esta alguns anos atrás
tive a oportunidade de visitar duas
prisões nas américas lado dos lados quer
poder ver a final do garcia morana no em
quito no equador
e do lado e tepic méxico na américa
visitará a presença de pepe por que dois
amigos tinham sido injustamente
encarcerados elano quando cheguei à
prisão e olha pra que o espaço enorme e
os presos todos andaram por lá e todo o
tempo que elas tinham de me falar com os
meus amigos e inspirar os vários livros
para que pudessem praticar yoga praticar
meditação e aproveitar o inúmero tempo
que tinham no fundo o tempo em que
explorava o seu julgamento
durante 18 anos e agora tem sido parte
da minha vida
yoga é uma filosofia que integra as três
grandes divisões do que ser com o ser
humano
a nossa - nosso corpo e o nosso espírito
o yoga trabalha com uma filosofia que
abrange a parte mental trabalha com
exercício físico e com uma ciência que
vai ao lado físico ao nosso corpo e
também é uma arte e ajuda nos a ver
melhor as qualidades e as instâncias do
nosso espírito
então a idéia para a qual nós fomos
premiados trata de criar um programa a
nível nacional uma plataforma que possa
reunir todas as pessoas de água que
sejam empossados e que sintam inspirados
a ensinar dentro do estabelecimento
prisional pessoas de olga e meditação
certificados que tenham experiência e
que possam vir a trazer os benefícios
destas técnicas prisionais portugueses
assim distribuímos os professores em
calendários com atividade para que
possam e semanalmente eles possam criar
um programa que vai ajudar a rede social
a transformação física ea sua
transformação mental cerebral
é fato que a maior parte dos
prisioneiros círculos sofrem de algum
tipo de trauma que foi causada na sua
infância na sua arrogância ou até na
idade adulta e muitas vezes são estes
traumas que não foram processados que
leva a cometer atos criminosos
eles são contra a lei do país onde está
então nós queremos ensinar o yoga com
uma ferramenta que vai ajudar os
prisioneiros a terem uma relação com o
seu próprio corpo e melhorar essa
relação estava sã a ligação entre o
corpo a mente eo espírito de forma que
possam também angerer melhor as suas
emoções
assim damos agapan vivo como ao completo
ao holístico
desta forma aumentar esta sensibilidade
temos a capacidade de olhar para os
outros de outra forma ganhar mais
empatia para com os outros
aumentar a nossa compaixão e reduzir no
limite o ciclo de violência e também a
restrição nos vícios
então o yoga da noite técnicas que
podemos usar não estava no tapete vamos
usar fora dão queremos usar dentro da
aula
vamos usar fora da aula e planos
integrar em todos os pontos da nossa
vida
a ideia é essa e aí é que vem o valor
transformacional do yoga durante uma
aula
nós só vamos ouvir e praticar o que o
professor não está a sugerir mas é na
nossa vida cotidiana vamos realmente ver
que estas ferramentas nos vão ajudar a
lidar com as nossas emoções
os novos stress e com a forma como vemos
a vida os benefícios são inúmeros e eu
suponho que tenho alguma idéia foi algo
ajuda a aliviar os 3 ajuda a aumentar a
tensão o foco a concentração dá nos
força a um show física quando nós nos
sentimos melhores e mais fortes que os
nossos corpos também vamos sentir melhor
e mais mais forte com a nossa autoestima
e com lançamento
o nosso pensamento se torna se mais
claro e mais não falta coisas por aí
além
então existem muitos casos de estudo e
de sucesso a nível internacional e eu
tive que estudar projetos nos estados
unidos que ocorre em vários estados na
china é frança em vários países da
comunidade européia e os resultados são
fantásticos
por isso a idéia era trazer o yoga e
meditação como uma prática para ajudar a
rede social para tentar uma nova
perspectiva de vida estas pessoas que
têm que estar o seu roteiro obrigatório
ea saudável adverte podem mudar podem se
transformar e podem criar na sua vida
uma coisa muito melhor
a meditação ajuda nos a ver as coisas
como elas são e yoga é sem dúvida um
caminho para a liberdade
quando conseguimos ver
um senhor completa obrigada
[Aplausos]